[Applause]
all right it's great to be here who knew
that i could stay up later than most
children in america it's true i can
it's fun to see exclamation points
everywhere around this set there's on
the posters on the name and also on the
please laugh signs i didn't know that
he had those but that actually probably
helps the show a little bit the set
staff was pleased because greg and i
share the same size booster seat and the
same size shoes
all right look for anyone battling
addictions or lots of big thorny
problems in their lives the first step
to recovery is admitting you have a
problem and that's not easy to do
then you have to accept that you have to
get up off your duff and commit to
making things better that's right i said
duff and that's the kind of salty
language language you will get from dana
perino after dark
so here's what you do you make a plan
you tackle the issue you try to change
your circumstances you get better
results and solve your problem you can't
just sit back blame others and expect
everything to be okay
or can you
let's see how the leader of the free
world is approaching his set of problems
he's setting records all over the place
record inflation record gas prices
record increases in crime which has led
to record low poll numbers the one thing
he's been able to do is bring everyone
together on one question
a whopping record 74 of people surveyed
in a recent poll believe the country is
on the wrong track
they've even broken the record for
audacity i mean you cannot help but
laugh at what the president thinks
should get glowing coverage the historic
airlift from afghanistan the historic
shipments of baby formula from europe
the historic release from our strategic
petroleum reserve
and he sounds like a broken record as he
tries to blame everyone but himself
this is
outrageous what the war
in ukraine is causing we've never seen
anything like putin's tax on both food
and gas exxon made more money than god
this year why aren't they drilling
because they make more money not
producing more oil
my republican colleagues say these
programs
to help the working class and middle
class people
that's they say that's why we have
inflation
they're dead wrong
under my predecessor
the great maggot king
the deficit increased every single year
he was president
he even has decided to blame his most
loyal remaining friends the media
look how the press has changed
look how the press is it has changed oh
listen i get it even the really good
reporters they have to get number clicks
on on on nightly news
so instead of asking a question
anyway it just everything gets
gets sensationalized
anyway
it got so bad that a couple of weeks ago
after going about 120 days without doing
a single interview with any reporter he
sauntered back to the press cabin on air
force one to complain about his press
coverage and get this
it was off the record
even the reporters were taken aback the
biden cabinet and his communications
team well they have picked up on this
don't blame us blame yourselves media
which is strange to me because i know
political communications very well i
mean has anyone in this room ever heard
that i was the white house press
secretary to president george w bush
i'm sure you've heard it i started out
as a young hill staffer well i don't get
applause
[Music]
i just thought it was funny that i also
i also say it way too much and everybody
certainly knows but anyway i didn't
start out as white house press secretary
i was a young staffer on the hill i had
all this optimism i'm super excited to
work with the fourth estate on making
sure that the issues were covered fairly
and that my republican congressman could
get a fair shot in the press
oh how innocent i was it lasted like
four days
you see the easiest job in washington is
a democratic communications staffer
the hardest job repairing the
teleprompter after kamala goes off
script
think about it the reporters write what
you want written they agree to keep your
comments to staffer more anonymous than
a list of men who watch the view
they run cover for you even the press
will write that it's not chess boudin's
fault that in san francisco there's
either fecal matter on or mass looting
on every street corner
in fact there are several jobs harder
than a democrat communications staffer
matchmaker for channing tatum
dwayne johnson's personal trainer
snack wrangler for brian stelter
sorry brian
i mean i'm just filling in here
and greg's personal shopper of course
and then the com staffers will laugh
behind the reporters backs knowing that
they've used them to meet their goals
but i do feel for the com staffer in a
way because here's a perino rule
whenever you hear that someone has a
communications problem say immediately
no communications problems are caused by
fact problems by policy problems and no
policy problem in the history of the
world was ever solved by a change in
messaging believe me i've tried larry
will remember that
this isn't a communications problem it's
a joe biden problem a communications
problem is when his mic doesn't work
a job item problem is when it does
the white house press office doesn't
have much to work with they aren't
making new policies watch here
understand that prices these gas prices
including food prices in particular
those two things as we we
look at inflation and trying to make
sure that we're fighting inflation in
every way that we can
is hurting uh families it's hurting
families especially as they sit around
their kitchen table
but we're going to continue to do
everything that we can
i don't have anything to preview for you
they're also living with the
consequences of biden's policies we all
are and we're reminded of it left and
right gas groceries baby formula the
list goes on
now how hard is it to figure out that
you can't message inflation away
anyways let's just say though that the
administration watches gut fell let's
say that you gut-felt exclamation point
they take my advice and they start to
admit that they have a problem and they
start to try to solve them
the last step to recovery would be next
and that is admitting your wrongs and
making amends to the american people
it's unlikely that the president will be
doing that so it's every man for himself
and at least we have each other
let's welcome tonight's guest he's like
a company that rents out bouncy houses
always worried about inflation he's the
host of kudlow on fox business larry
kudlow
he's on a number of who's who list
because no one knows who he is he's the
host of fox across america jimmy fella
for him working remotely means moving to
alaska actor writer and comedian jamie
lasalle
and she gets carried away when holding
helium filled balloons fox news
contributor cat tim
all right so we're in there's no turning
back now larry do you think president
biden runs again in 2024 and if he
decides not to is it age or is the
economy not going to get any better
well it could be
both got to be both
i mean
i don't want to be accused of ageism so
i'll just stay with all his policy
mistakes i really liked your a.a 12-step
routine you you've got to you've got it
i nail it you've got to own it and
you've got to deal with it and when you
were wrong you should promptly admit it
of course they won't do that he's living
in some kind of alternate universe and
unfortunately the country's paying the
price for this right now you see an
inflation record stocks are getting
killed interest rates have gone up real
wages are falling you went through the
list i happen to agree he can't possibly
run on that record so
i think he's probably too old okay but i
really don't want to weigh inflation
like there's they can't start talking
about it in a different way and make
inflation better well your other point
is exactly right there's no such thing
as a communications problem it's about
policy and substance and what you're
doing and are you helping the country
you're hurting the country everybody in
the country outside of the white house
understands that the country is vastly
worse off so he can't possibly run but
look the semifinals is going to be
in november he's going to get
slaughtered the cavalry's coming and
things are going to get better i like to
be an optimist yes you are that's why we
love you when we keep having you back
this
this this must change and as always the
case in america which is the greatest
country it will i agree indeed
absolutely jimmy can the media be better
when it comes to biden's press coverage
can they be more helpful to him no
because every question is a tough
question
when you ask joe biden what state he's
in he gets it wrong quite frequently
so what are we supposed to do with joe
biden the only guy we know who quits
talking in the middle of a sentence
because he's done you understand
like dude this guy is sending in the
punt team on second down that's not how
it's supposed to work
i would love to see him run again though
just because somebody would have to sell
this i like could you imagine asking the
american people to vote for this guy
again that's like handing out cruise
brochures on a lifeboat from the titanic
but think about monday through thursday
weren't those good dinners
like seriously
but seriously here's the only upside to
the biden presidency and i've combed
high and low you know i'm a silver
lining guy and i really am the only
improvement in the quality of life under
biden is that arsons are down 91 because
no one can burn down your house at 5 15
a gallon that's where we are
that's it
that's it if someone burns down your
house right now dana you should be
flattered like they really can't
that's it they have all those
hard-earned dollars
cat the calls are coming from inside the
house now the democrats are now the ones
saying to whispering to the new york
times anonymously like you can't be our
nominee in 2024. yeah but i think that
they
still don't really get it some of the
people in that article who were on the
record like david axelrod saying well
the one of the problems is that biden
looks his age and i'm like i don't think
lip injections are going to solve this
and he actually does prove to me i
finally now understand what age is just
a number means because like my
grandparents are like 10 years older
than joe biden and they're way better
at words
i would be so concerned if i heard
either one of them talking like this and
they're not the leader of the free world
i think that people are more concerned
about
everything that's going wrong there's
inflation people are struggling and it's
you know kind of the equivalent of when
you send a friend a text and they really
need some help you have a really bad day
and they go damn that sucks
that's what he's doing and all those
press conferences like well you know
yeah we know we're working but are you
people want to it's not just that things
are bad as people have no confidence
that anything's going to get better and
as greg said last week he always
explains what inflation is like
we know we feel it every single day um
greg sent in a question for you
so i would never say this
[Laughter]
as a divorced man do you blame all your
problems on your ex-wife
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i'll be honest with you i definitely
blame her for the divorce
it was her idea
but danny you were so right in your
monologue that this is not a
communication problem it is a fact
problem even in just the short clips we
saw he said exxon has more money than
god i don't think god even has money
like in every picture i've seen he
doesn't even have pockets
you know
and like
did you guys read the there was one
article that didn't quite like the text
didn't quite come up and what we've
talked about so far but it was biden
complaining saying people kept throwing
things on his desk like every time i
look up there's like more stuff to do
people get throwing stuff on my desk i'm
like yeah you're like the president
right
like there's stuff to do and that's not
just stuff those are life-saving
medications
[Laughter]
don't you think it's where the i think i
think cat is so right that age really is
just a number and we know people that
are much older that are spry and sharp
and this is j and people i've heard
people say like he's an old 79
and um i like to put a positive spin on
i think he's more like a young 115.
you know
or like a youthful dracula monster
but you know can i just say yes um
if
the economy were booming
and prices were stable and gasoline was
low where donald trump left at i might
add if the united states was respected
around the world if and so a lot of ifs
if he hadn't bungled afghanistan
i don't think anybody would care about
his age that's why i hate to make the
age point too hard i mean
i don't know enough about all that all
i'm saying is it's what he's done and
then the harm he's done to the country
through his policies and the fact that
as you mentioned earlier he won't
acknowledge any of it he's never to
blame the guy is the sort of least
introspective person i've ever seen in
my life and that's what's killing him
all right up next is crime consuming
conversations in areas with sparse
populations hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else